don't you hate it when you get to the
airport on time the weather's fine but
your flight is delayed because of air
traffic gridlock stuck on the ground
officially late more than 92 percent of
the time passengers spent the next six
hours on that jet how could our traffic
gridlock cause delays when there's so
much empty sky for planes to fly in
here's the problem the air traffic
control system in the United States
today is technologically obsolete
Robert W Poole jr. is director of
transportation studies at Reason
Foundation this model is basically the
same model we've been using since the
beginning of air travel back then they'd
write down the flight info put it on one
of these little white blocks and move
the blocks around that's really how air
traffic controllers kept track of planes
in the sky an important and familiar
part of this crew is the smiling hosted
or stewarded social dorrance were just
as old-fashioned as the technology he
must be healthy single and between the
ages of 21 and 28 at least delays
weren't so bad because there weren't
that many planes flying since then air
traffic has increased by about 3,000
percent hostesses are now flight
attendants who can be men or women of
any age and how about those old white
blondes have they been computerized nope
they're still used today you wouldn't
believe how backward the technology is
today we have radar but we've had radar
since the 1950s as the means that tells
the controller where the plane is but
it's not very precise it's only updated
about once every 12 seconds and it's 500
miles an hour our plane can go quite a
ways in that time the technology the
Federal Aviation Administration or FAA
uses to navigate
million-dollar airliners is less
advanced than the GPS technology we use
to navigate $20,000 cars the system
can't handle as many planes as it could
if we had a more precise information in
real time about where they are air
travel is increasing so expect our
creaky old system to stick you with even
more delays in the future we could avoid
that fate with better technology that
would allow us to fly more planes and do
it safely so why can't the government
bring the system into the 21st century
welcome to the John Murtha Johnstown
Cambria County Airport with a seven
million dollar air traffic control tower
a 14 million dollar hangar and an 18
million dollar runway the problem is how
politicians spend money this is the John
Murtha Airport at 10:30 in the morning
there is nobody here seems like the
Pennsylvania Airport attracts more
reporters than passengers even so the
airport was just awarded another eight
hundred thousand dollars in federal
stimulus money to repave an alternate
runway so much scrutiny over is pork
Stravaganza but Congressman John Murtha
is proud of his Airport
Martha's earmarking of grants for his
Airport in Johnstown is is a you know a
classic example of the excesses that
Congress does maybe the only way to get
the politics out of our air traffic
system is to take the system away from
the politicians some say we should let a
corporation manage the skies people are
talking about running our air traffic
control system like a big private
corporation that means putting profits
before people the air traffic
controllers Union runs ads criticizing
the proposal
and to many it sounds like a far-out
free-market idea to have a private
company running air navigation system
but it turns out Canada disagrees Nav
Canada is the private company that runs
Canada's air navigation system the
second biggest in the world here in
Canada
folks often take pride in their nation's
lavish government programs yet Canadians
allow Nav Canada a private company to
manage their skies and the idea of
running the air traffic control system
like a business often called
commercialization enjoys the support of
some prominent Democrats one of the
biggest champions of this during the
Clinton years of ATC reform was Al Gore
he was committed to it and if you
stopped him on the street today and
asked him about it he could tell you a
lot about it during the Clinton
administration
Bob stone was selected by Vice President
Al Gore to direct Gore's reinventing
government initiative which was designed
to make government smarter slimmer and
more efficient and now it's my honor to
introduce our leader in reinventing the
federal government the Vice President of
the United States Al Gore in reinventing
government I didn't have a lot of great
ideas and Al Gore didn't have a lot of
great ideas what we had was the ability
to look around see where something is
really working well and say we want to
do that here in the United States in
Canada had a successful model they had
an air traffic control corporation was
controlled by the airlines operating as
a business and controlling air traffic
and that's what we wanted here why did
they want it better technology for one
remember those little white blocks the
ones used way back when to keep track of
planes the ones the u.s. still uses Nav
Canada has computerized that and Canada
is moving away from radar technology
faster than the US
Canada's reform has completely deep
politicized aircraft control in America
politicians control funding and red tape
often thwarts equipment upgrade
but nab canada's funding comes directly
from airlines and if the company wants
new technology it just buys it
whereas tired of flight delays as you
are but America's air traffic
controllers Union is not impressed but
selling our air traffic system to the
highest bidder and putting safety at
risk is not a solution can we really
trust a private company with something
as important as aviation just about all
of aviation is done by private companies
the planes are made by private companies
the airlines are private for-profit
companies nobody makes a long-term
business out of killing their customers
bureaucracy and red tape frustrate the
American people gore stone and Poole
agree that the US should convert its air
traffic system from a government
bureaucracy to a self-supporting
nonprofit corporation
after all since commercialization
Canada's already safe skies have become
even safer the technology because of all
the real-time information available for
everyone means that if something does go
wrong you spot it more quickly and can
take corrective action so what happened
to Al Gore's attempt to modernize our
old-fashioned air traffic control system
it was a wonderful idea and it went
absolutely nowhere Congress just doesn't
like to give up control of anything
there's some things that the government
has to do there's some things the
government is very good at but air
traffic control is something the
government doesn't have to do and it's
not very good so the next time your
plane is delayed think about why you're
stuck maybe it's because of the weather
or maybe it's because of politics for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie